okay good afternoon i have derek hello
good here at north georgia technical
college i've got a little video for you
all this afternoon here a practical
machinist that i wanted to show you all
about how to do
some mason troll programming relief um
this is a part that i have my lab
operations 2 class make um one of those
things i have them make well i'll just
show you the entire thing so you can get
you can get
a
idea what we're talking about one of the
things i'll have them make is an entire
bottle jack and i have some students to
get really close to get it complete and
get it put together but it's all the
different components
that go together to make this piece
right here it's quite a little
fascinating project with some
interesting operations you have to do
both for the lathe and mill
well one of the pieces is this needle
valve right here this is what opens up
the
valving to let the fluid return to the
cylinder up in here
so basically the red reservoir that is
from the cylinder
so that allows you to be able to
depressurize it so if i turn this into
where you can see
the wire frame you should be able to see
yeah there you go you can see it there
so you see the needle valve goes into
this piece right here
and it seals off this port here
the needle valve is open it allows the
fluid to come back out of the cylinder
and into the reservoir back up in here
so that's an important pieces of this
well
one of the things we have started to do
with our students is we're you know
introducing more and more conversational
programming on the mesa glades that we
have and i was trying to figure out
something i can have them do and i saw
this needle valve would be a great piece
for that
okay now let's talk about why i
dimension this the way i did
what i need to do is basically duplicate
this shape as it goes along here
and for my basic profile so basically
i'm going to start here this end right
here and work my way over entering the
dimensions that you see here now i have
two options one
i can go from this point to here
to here
up the top of the chamfer
over to this point down at the chamfer
to this point to this point to this
point
to here to here or
i can do from here to here
to here
then there's a button that allows me to
do a chamfer
to this square corner back up to this
point right here and then do a chamfer
there straight over do a chamfer again
on that there come over here
feed up to here to chamfer there
both work and they'll both create the
same profile
it's just you know two different ways to
do it
um
personally to make it a little bit
simpler i think i'm going to go with the
the second option here be a little bit
less data points have to enter so i'm
gonna start here and start working my
way through this so my first point is
going to be a
zero zero point right here
pull a table over here so i just have to
flip around as much
okay
so
let me
start here at the beginning so i got
zero zero here
so i'm going to start building my shape
go back to the program here
i want to go to bar right here
let's give you my options here got a lot
of different options there
i'm going to go out here
cutting point x where does it start my
cutting point at
is going to be um
my 0.38
sorry these are not showing up great
when i type them in here you can see
them up here though
cutting point z is going to be my zero
point
finish x finish the
in this case i'm gonna do like a five
thousandth finish allowance on it here
point zero zero five
and put the same thing on my access
point zero
[Music]
okay
next comes up with my tools here
i'm going to change my finishing tool
here though i have a reason for that but
i'm going to stick with this roughing
torch you've got there
number my pattern here
which one i want to use in this case
right here
one and two depends on how it retracts
out
two
threes kind of interrupted cut here what
cuts along and have to stop here i'm
just gonna go my zero here
on that
speeds and feeds let me go carbide auto
that again
it's going to calculate
all this out now one change i'm going to
make here because i'm dealing with a
pretty small piece it calls for a depth
of 100 thousandths here
that ain't going to quite work for me so
i'm going to go about 20 thousandths
there
come over to my feed
turn my
coin on
here and go down here to this now i told
you i'm going to change my tool here i'm
going to go to my nominal here
and i want to click on my tool data
window here
i want to change it to this one
tool number two
and tool number eight are the two tools
i have turning tools i have in here
if you look inside of here
you see tool eight
have a sharper point
tool through has a
a uh
shallower angle there's not quite a
scape of an angle
tool two
will not get into here as good as tool
eight will till it will pretty much be
able to rough this out and give me a
usable relief here
i could come back in and do some do a
groove here if i needed to but i
shouldn't really need it
with that tool number eight there so i
want to change this
to my nominal eight degree
number eight here it's called
about eight degrees
come over scroll down scroll across
carbide auto again
get my feed turn my coin on again
going on again
there we go
so now i get to start my building my
profile
first move is going to be on a taper
move so because that taper there
start
doesn't want a radius or chamfer there i
do not there start point x
is going to be
zero
start point v is gonna be zero
finish point x is going to be point one
eight seven
finish point z
it's gonna be that point five three i
have right here
[Music]
so go to the
point five sorry there
[Applause]
any radius there no
angle there no
roughness once again i can do right here
with this
i'm gonna go about eight on this one
that's my first move
my second move is gonna be a straight
line move
back to here
so i go to linear
you see linear doesn't give you a
starting stop point because it's going
to start and stop where you left off
that before
and then scroll over to
here
and i want this to cut
2.187 again
there and my feed point here
is going to be the 0.999
so i'm gonna go
0.99999
and we're
good thing
okay scroll down my next one
now
making sure i remember this correctly on
this has been a little bit since i've
programmed this
um
this is how it finishes up the like the
corner there in that case i didn't need
that i need to actually have my chamfer
right here on the next line here
so i got a linear move here again
i'm gonna have a start chamfer 0.029
that is my
chamfer
that i have here
my next move is going to move over to
1.436
so i'm going to go to a start point
final finish point x right here point
two five
and i wanna go to 1.436
my next move right here is going to be a
linear move again
it's going to have the same chamfer cut
on it
and it's going to go back to 0.187
there
it's going to maintain that same 1.436
what i'm doing there is i'm bringing it
back down into here
next move it's going to be over to
1.4561
it's give me a linear move
it's another linear move here
nothing here
my x value
3.187
my z
is going to be 1.561
[Applause]
so that matches up to what i have on the
print here
next move it's going to go up to my full
diameter here this is going to be point
it's going to be a linear move again
linear move
and i want
0.375 right here
and it's going to stay in the 1.561
[Applause]
next move
it's going to be a linear move again
it's going to have a chamfer here of
[Applause]
0.046
so i enter 0.046
not zero
can't wait to be zero zero point zero
four six
okay
three point three seventy five
and it's going to go to
[Music]
two point zero
six one
2.061
[Applause]
next move
i'm gonna do another little linear move
down here i'm gonna cut myself kind of
like a little
face it down here to get that
it is going to go to
point
right there
got a champer here also 0.046
chamfer my dimensions will be 0.283
and it's going to cut let's just say
basically back to
2.061
there we go and one more move here
linear move point two eight three good
again and let's go to like two and a
quarter here point two point three five
so you give me an area for my parting
tool
to come in there kind of pre-release
that down a little bit
and that is the end of my shape
to do shape in
let's take a look at my shape here
and see what we got if i do shape unit
here it draws ones out you can see how
it drew out the facing
and there is
our piece
so there you go
that's what we're making
so that is a turning process on this
now the next one we go into is going to
go into the threading
then we'll talk about the parts catcher
and the um
grooving that's necessary on this
okay next we're going to do our
threading operation here so we're going
to click our thread button here
give me an external yeah internal
face or back thread here we're gonna
outside here
chamfer i'm gonna go with no here which
is a zero entry
thread lead
now lead
okay let's do a little math here already
pre-did this for us
on a single lead thread pitch and lead
are equal to each other in this case we
got a quarter 28
well
28 threads per inch is what we need so
i need to enter on this right here my my
my pitch here for my lead because it's
going to be the same thing because
there's only one start location so 1
divided by 28 gives me a
pitch of 0.0351429
i'm gonna go about four decimal places
on that so point zero three five seven
for that
so that's gonna be the number i'm going
to enter right here point zero three
five
seven
angle so it's gonna be a sixty degree
number of entrances one there
height and it can auto correct calculate
that
that's going to give me my height value
there
got my thread tool automatically pulled
up my thread tool here that's good
come over
number of pattern here
i've got some options here i got
standard i got constant depth constant
area
standard constant
depth constant area there um
i'm just going standard on this one it
should work fine for what we're doing
here
click auto set on my depths there
let's give you how many passes it takes
seven passes in this case
cutting speed i'm gonna go carbide auto
on this
392 feet per minute and i'm going to
turn my coolant
on
let's go around
start point x
start point z
start point x in this case is going to
be my 0.25
start point z
my threads start at one inch i'm going
to start a little bit off it
this machine does a really really nice
job of being able to start where you
want it to and through it that we wanted
to so i'm gonna go about .875
my z point eight seven five
my finish point x
is gonna be .25
my finish point z
in this case let's see 1.56 is where my
shoulders at
so i'm going to call it about one and a
half should be good there it gets me
right in the middle of that relief there
this one also does a really good job of
managing threading i mean better than
any other machine i've ever ran
and we're good there was shape so that's
gives me my shape here
so that's it
threading's done
shape check once again guess my steps
here
you got my
the facing operation
you got the
contour
and you get your threads
you can see it starts a little bit off
the thread and it finishes up in that v
groove there
so that's good to go
okay the next part on this i'm going to
call up my parts catcher
and
part my tool off and it's my first
picture home
now
it'd be nice if they had a simple little
way to do this and it's not bad once
you've done it once
but to make my life simpler i have done
this i'm going to show you how i've done
it
and then i'm going to show you
what else necessary for the statue run
for my compass sub program i've created
my subprogram
is going to be
my subprogram number's gonna be 100.
what that is
is a
program i have written to just for the
purpose of calling up my parch catcher
how many times it repeats it one
i don't need anything there in my
sequence we're good there
then i'm going to go to my t groove
me go t groove out
how what kind of groove do i want give
me some options here it's a straight up
groove here this is just me to part my
part off
number of grooves one groove there
pitch is going to be the same as my tool
width is going to be the same as my tool
there
okay so i'm going to go to a
grooving tool here 120 thousandths
basically 118 measured i believe it is
come over here to my next piece right
here go to my depths
carbide auto on that is how much it goes
in before it retracts
speeds and feeds that's good there
feed rate carbide auto there
going on we're good
now i'll start my shape here
my shape and i want to show you one
thing here
i've got some options here let me get my
pulled out a window
i have
three
different
designations for my grooming tool tool 4
a b and c
now
the difference in those three is which
side of the tool
this pull is touching so i'm going to
show you how you can figure that out
i know which one it is let's show you
how to figure this out
come over here to my tool
page here
okay if you look at my z value on these
right here
negative
5.251
negative 5.370
negative five point three
one one
my home position is over here
so the bigger that negative value
is
the further this way it is
a
is
the seventh thought
being
here
is
and c's in the center i did that
deliberately because there's times i
needed i needed all three of those so i
want to use b in this case
so
if i go back to my program
here you'll see how
it's calling up tool a i've called up a
automatically i want to change that to b
which is my
tool that's got the right designation
for me
starting point x 0.375
their starting point z
is going to be
my 2.061
[Music]
[Applause]
2.061
finish point x
is going to be
zero
and finish point z
in this case right here i'm going to add
i think we're good there that 2.061
remember correctly on this
about 2.61 2.06
2.061
there we go taper angle is zero there
roughness good eight on this we're good
let's check my shape and see what we
look like here
okay you see how it's drawing my groove
right here
that's okay because
when the wave i have my tool
orientated
if i was pulling off the other side of
my tool
i would have to it would look
differently here so we see this just
just run you'll see what i mean by this
okay program
now
my parts catcher's out it's done my part
off i need to send my first catcher home
somebody come over here match the over
arrow again
get a sub program
work number here is 101
which is the one i have to
do
the parts get your home
and then
go to my last little bit click my end
unit here
does it continue in that case no
zero for that
parts counter no zero for that
return i want to send it to my zero
position there and we're good to go
now let's take a look at this the two
things on this
take a look at watch this run on the
tool path
and then
go about okay so i'll draw my part shape
in there
and i'm gonna click my path continue
see the facing
the turning of it down
finishing off it threading
and then the parting right there you see
how it shows draws a line right there
but since my offset is where it's out
it's going to part my piece off right
there where i want it to that's good by
the way times you see that travel over
this way right here is where it went
home
for the parts catcher
now
let me show you what i'm talking about
by the parts catcher program
program work number let's go to 100 here
let's call it up here it's a simple
program the step at the top doesn't
really matter
manual programming i put my groove tool
in there so they basically didn't do a
tool change
right here so i had to go to a manual
program for this
so i come down here
i have an option here a manual program
i pulled manual program and asked me to
what i want to do here
and i sent it home
g28u
w for my x and z
over there
m code
m48
is the one called the parts catcher
that's the end unit right there
we're all good
the one to send at home horse catcher
retract
is the same with an m49 here instead
so if i go to my m codes here let's see
if it actually shows me that i'm trying
to remember it's been a while since i
set this one up
for that
and it does
not automatically give me that one so
that's what i had to look up in the
manual for this thing
to find what it was
so there you go
that's what i would had to enter
manually in there for this to work
so it worked
works well does what we expect out of it
overall
makes a good part
okay i am derek hogan with north georgia
technical college coming to you today
from for practical machinists i
appreciate you taking the time to watch
these videos i hope you've enjoyed them
i really hope you enjoyed today's video
if you have any comments questions or
concerns
be sure to put those in the comment
section and do not forget to like and
subscribe thank you so much for your
time
you